hey guys this is andrew from
trainsenses.com i'm professional trader
for the past six years in hong kong and
i've been working for several big
investment banks like hsbc or commerce
bank
and i've just started to make some
youtube videos where i share with you
guys all my experience of six years of
pro training
so i use technical analysis a lot to
help me to take any trading decision
and i want to tell you guys what is
working for me and what is not so if you
want to know
how to use all these techniques and to
know which stocks to me are hot right
now
you are in the right place so today i
want to talk about fubu tv and bbb
why let's get into it
[Music]
so uh for those who saw my previous
videos i basically hang out a lot on
wall street bets you know so i did my
reddit account so you know you can find
this kind of stuff you know
so this is quite a funny but basically
you have
some information about jimmy and i go on
twitter as well you know
and you can find a lot of guys that
actually share the list of the stocks
that things
are gonna go higher in the coming weeks
so i
analyzed all the stocks uh so i did my
own list guys by hanging out there
so i had like more than 20 of them at
the beginning even more than this
and i have here a short list that to me
are the winners
so i'm not buying on all of them but
there is an action to take for
almost all of them i check the market
capitalization and then check the short
interest
once again guys uh the market cap is
important because if it's small enough
then uh when the registers are gonna
enter all together in the stock that can
have an impact on it and is if the short
interest is big enough as well which
which means there are a lot of hedge
funds that are short of this stuff
then the short squeeze is likely to
happen and this is
what uh we are looking for any short
squeeze situation
that is likely to happen so i did clvs
amc before
right now i'm gonna go do a fubu and bbb
why so first thing market cap six
and three billion so let's do football
first so six billion usd
all right so it's quite big for this
penny stocks are it's much bigger than
clds and imc like uh two to five times
and the short interest is around 40
which is quite high
so let's look at the technicals so
basically the stock is going
uh lower for the past five years all
right it was at 18 000 guys it was a
dramatic
drop it lost 99.99
it's insane i i think i've never seen
something that dropped that much you
know so that's why guys enough
you should not buy everything because as
you can see something can
drop you know forever almost but now we
have some
bullish signals that started to appear
uh in 2020
and so the major support i see here
is at 23 guys all right so if you are
not long the staff
you can always buy some here and hope
it's going to go higher but
this is not trading if you want to do
proper trading you buy at 22 you put a
stop loss at 20
right so you have 10 percent maximum
loss
and you can make much more guys because
if you buy here you can make 300
only to the first resistance level so if
you're along the staff i know
some of you guys along uh i won't give
the name here
but i do this video because some people
told me fubo
is hot and i agree it is hot
it will probably go higher the
so the first resistance level is at 57
because it's the recent high we had here
but it's not strong
it was just uh rejected once and
i think we're gonna go higher just
technically speaking
the earnings are very bad but guys
that's why there is a lot of short
interest and what we are looking
here for is a short squeeze so my
sending target will be at 120
i just take the height that is here and
the next one is at 500
so there is a lot of upside potential on
this stock
that's it for this one so let's go to
bbb
wire so dvy has three billion market cap
so it's smaller which is better and more
uh short interest 66 which means that 66
percent of the people who are long the
share
lended to some hedge funds against a
borrow rate
so that the hedge fund can short it all
right so guys usually you have
around five percent you know of short
interest in a normal share
and five is a lot tesla has eight for
example and it's very high
so one percent apple has one percent all
right so when you have 66
it really means that there is a lot of
guys that showed this stuff
this way guys looks beautiful all right
so first earnings are positive
so means the company is doing better the
hedge funds might cut the position
earlier because the fundamentals are
better and here guys
when i do the donuts downward sloping
trendline that started in 2015
you can see guys this is a nice behavior
i like this
this one because it has been broken here
and
you can see that it was as well the
highest level we had in 20 i mean deck
19. it's almost the same and at this
level we have a double signal guys we
have the down swapping trend line that
has been bridged and we have the high
the highest level of 20 that has been
broken as well
then we go higher we re-test it
three times and then we go higher so
guys this is a very strong
area of support so now we are 26 once
again
don't buy it here guys be patient there
are a lot of them wait for the
right timing all right so here 25 lower
at 18
you can buy it and it's nice to buy and
once again
where are our targets guys our targets i
always do the same stuff
which is quite efficient i take i try to
see where i had some consolidation so
here you see i had
some so here it's exactly exactly where
we are
so this is another support level you can
buy some here and just stop us below but
i mean
this one is not very strong then here
and then
here all right so it can go up 200
percent
right so it's not like fubo uh tv but
there is a lot of potential on the
upside and here the earnings are
positive all right for football the
the the earnings are very negative guys
so the hedge fund might
um increase their short position all
right that's it for me we're gonna
do the next ones very soon guys so if
you enjoyed this video
please click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new about
this stuff
and stay close to show i'll see you guys